naja das luft ist natürlich eine ganz
gute idee aber doch nur da wo wird
tatsächlich auch mit coronaviren rechnen
müssen
also wenn ich zu hause in meinem
wohnzimmer sitze dann muss ich mir dann
muss sie nicht erfrieren weil
irgendjemand sagt das müsse gelüftet
werden es müssen doch menschen da sein
die das krone wo es ausatmen auspusten
ausließen sonst macht auch das lüften
überhaupt gar keinen sind genauso muss
man sich das auch überlegen bei den
schulklassen natürlich aber überlegen
sie doch mal wir haben als 25 30 kinder
in der klasse wo sollen denn die ganzen
coronaviren alle herkommen also dass
regelmäßiges lüften pause zum unterricht
pause zwischen zwei stunden das ist acht
richtig dann aber auch nicht vernünftig
wäre bestimmt damit einmal die luft aber
wirklich ausgetauscht aber was ich schon
gehört habe dass manche schulen den
ganzen tag jetzt die fenster offen
lassen um die kinder dann praktisch im
ziel anzukommen sitzen müssen das ist
doch völlig schwachsinnig ja genauso
alle 20 minuten so schnell können sie
die luft gar nicht anreichern und dann
im man muss auch mal kalkulieren wir
reden immer davon dass die kinder gar
nichts fertigungs fähig sind dass sie
gar nicht so viel übertragen und dann
noch einmal wird jetzt praktisch die
schule auf den kopf gestellt also wenn
wir da immer in der pause einmal läuft
dann ist das völlig ausreichend
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren